having at Tyler works with the ladies
true or false Tyler you got your
prospectus we'll do it like 7:00 p.m.
we'll go into 3:00 in the morning if I
have to you get the hang right here with
us
twitch the video going music going
December 2014
lock it in just block it right now
September 24 it's gonna be the date see
ya everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 294 the ask gary vee
show this an exciting episode for me as
you can see i'm perched outside my
office i have a small group of friends
here we did a really fun barter party
for the clouds and dirt your grand plan
to buy the New York Jets if you buy
brands grow them yes what is your
criteria for buying these birds
opportunity costs meaning I'm gonna wait
to the economy collapses and I'm gonna
bottom feed okay you know yeah I think
the world's gonna melt in the next two
to seven years who knows why not if I
did I would trade that way and hopefully
I'll be in a financial position which is
how I'm dealing with cash and investment
and vaynermedia to buy something that
today would cost me three hundred thirty
million and I could buy it for twenty
seven I don't show your young dude a lot
of people don't realize how bad it gets
when [ __ ] really hits the fan like we
for again it's been a great economy now
for nine years so like for a lot of
people under you know if you're under 32
if you're 32 and under you don't even
know what real life looks like in a bad
economy and if you even if you're 35 you
were still kind of young and you're like
probably 22 23 24 so you don't weren't
affected so like you almost have to be
like 40
today to even have like a good
contextual concept of what happens
minimally got to be 32 because you
remember it was hard to get a job yes so
yeah I mean I don't think people
understand they're like everybody's
gonna go out of business
look I only want to buy one if you
notice the numbers like let's not like I
want to buy a bunch of things for a
million I want to buy Twix I want to buy
k-swiss I want to buy you know panas on
I mean these you know whatever it may be
a Captain Crunch or I like nostalgia cuz
I think I just have those things that
everybody listening is like oh I know
that oh I know that versus I'm gonna
start fresh fresh cereal there's so much
money in the nostalgia of that kind of
brand awareness
I mean look look what I'm doing I've
been spending my I've been bleeding my
face off to create brand awareness and
still 99% America doesn't know who I am
yet 99% of America knows exactly what
Captain Crunch is if a business smaller
large was wanting to buy an Instagram
account for us to be a marketing arm for
them how would you recommend going about
finding the account and the name of they
like and DMing the person saying how
much do you want for this account just
straight-up strawberries like if you're
an ice cream store and you've got nine
locations in Baltimore the first thing I
do is go check out ice cream like the
account ice cream which will be which
will be expensive you know but some
people own names like somebody hit me up
the other night is like y'all my friend
owns this account I think it was like
three letters that made a word and
they're like and they're being offered
four hundred thousand for the Instagram
account I'm like sell it and sell it now
because like I know you can buy good
names for ten thousand so like so you
never know that was the extreme one way
you might hit up ice cream and it might
be some kid who's like 5,000 bucks mad
you know you never know okay okay Tyler
get Tyler real quick while you're
talking I'm gonna find out how much
Tyler's been offered for Tyler owns at
Tyler Oh on Instagram and I'm curious
while we're doing this episode if I can
find out from him
the actual prices ya wondering yeah hate
I have you but you know I love this
podcast sorry everybody listening to
podcasts have you ever been offered an
actual number for Tyler an actual number
not theory yes how much cool you past
huh yeah okay I think he passed because
I think having at Tyler works with the
ladies and I think that for me it's a
leverage in society and culture that he
doesn't want to give up Tyler
true or false true or false Tyler
[Music]
here's what I would tell you the one
thing you have to give a lot of thought
to think about is the market that you
play in is volatile like when the
economy collapses people get smoked out
and so you just need to be really
thoughtful as you make your content to
talk about the downside cuz a lot of
this stuff works
when economy's good yeah so just be
thoughtful that you're over
communicating like yo homies this is
right now but don't over leverage
yourself because you're gonna get
[ __ ] caught you know what's gonna
happen when the [ __ ] hits a pandora's if
I guarantee said it people are so
focused on the negativities of social
and digital without realizing how much
positivity there is just in the shear
axis correct positive information right
you find what you're looking for you
want to get sad go read all the racist
me to Russia
hacking negative stuff it's there
unlimited you want to be happy go find
all the obnoxious amounts of free
content around happiness self
fulfillment positivity it's all there
you find what you're looking for
listen I realize it everyone's always
like Gary you don't even know I'm like
I'll [ __ ] no I'm not gonna talk about
it every day it's a little obnoxious but
I realized it more than anybody will
ever realize I know exactly how this
[ __ ] games being played what's
happening who's getting impacted why the
scale of it and you know God willing if
I'm able to stay healthy and not have
anything terrible happen I can leave a
real [ __ ] program
I think audio is super important yeah
like I would couldn't push you enough to
consider like as you're doing video to
like convert it into audio podcasts I
think audio is a big space it's like
that stands out yeah audio is something
that you couldn't be first shonduras
popped because he moved on snapchat
first yeah
first mover matters so like being a
leader and audio or like [ __ ] with
audio and collabing I would [ __ ] go
on your Instagram and search your zip
code or town and just see what's poppin
and see somebody who's winning it's like
a funny guy a model a sports guy just
DMing people be like yo you want a Jam
couldn't believe people already roi big
[Music]
this is very smart too my friend you're
gonna make your money on this one day
smart Wow I am even starting to buy
these I'm buying them like cuz I can't
get them anymore be thoughtful of where
technology stops and we're
accountability as right tools I'm
telling you because I've been through it
tools are gonna disappoint you if you
don't have the right people there's two
things if you're trying to build a SAS
product or an app that's a whole
different story than if you're building
something internal for your team I think
that's an interesting way to go I
understand I got it you build something
for yourself and then wow if we can
scale it Wow I get it in watching a lot
of things casting has been the bigger
issue and way to fix things for people
then utilities not reinventing what a
football team does just getting a better
quarterback at left tackle not creating
some new scheme that has never been
invented run the ball on every play flea
flickers on every third play
not that it's replace your right guard
and so and so it's something worth
debating because what I will do if
nothing else what I'm excited about when
you leave right now I'm hoping that this
energy will run through your mind
so that
when you look at something you're like
is this a utility thing or a casting
thing the whole reason out of the plane
was because that is exactly the activity
that resonates very strongly my impetus
to start my company was overcoming fear
destroying any anxiety and taking all
the right steps which include or myself
out of play
[Music]